good morning good afternoon good evening
wherever you are hello
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message today is february 3rd
2022 we are live streaming as always on
rumble youtube and blaze tv
uh do me a favor particularly if you're
not watching on rumble think about that
because they're a completely
uncensorious place that does not depress
us in the algorithm or unsubscribe you
or make you not see our videos in your
feed
and that's kind of stuff i like so uh
check out our rumble page if you haven't
uh very important today this is this is
big stuff we've got some breaking news
right now at the top of the show
breaking news this is just breaking let
me put on my news person glasses we have
an update ladies and gentlemen an update
breaking right now
uh yes i'm being told we have an update
on how many people
have been killed because of the joe
rogan podcast okay so i'm just getting
this live they just handed me these
papers and as you know there's been a
big brouhaha joe rogan has you know
these long three-hour conversations with
all sorts of people experts in fields uh
actors mma fighters interesting people
they talk about things joe's a curious
guy and as you know the mainstream media
the blue czech npc people
washed up musicians they're trying to
take joe rogan out because of all of the
people that have directly
died as the at the as the result of the
joe rogan podcast the joe rogan program
there we have updated numbers right now
breaking news ladies and gentlemen joe
rogan has killed zero people
zero people
think about that okay
i want you to think about that all right
guys we got four stories for you today
actually three current event stories and
one throwback i've been trying to get
these throwbacks mixed in and we thought
this would be a good one for today uh
first we're going back to canada because
there's just a lot going on there and
this trucker protest
is actually breaking through there are
politicians actually saying we might
change our policies and that justin
trudeau is still in hiding which is
pretty great uh second story
is a little juxtaposition of life in
florida versus life in california i will
be putting five dollars in the old tip
jar
as you guys know every time i mention
california on this show i'm gonna put
five bucks in a jar and at the end of
the year we're going to count all that
money up and i'm going to give that
money to someone who wants to move from
california to florida we're at about 60
bucks or so
i'm going to put in 10 today i feel that
this story is worth i'm going to just
show you the the idiocy happening in
california versus the good stuff
happening here right in florida third
the big story of yesterday which broke
while we were live speaking of breaking
news is that jeff zucker the ceo the
president of cnn he has resigned in
shame
although he should really be more shamed
by the ratings of cnn rather than this
sort of what i what appears to be mostly
a kind of nonsensical insider scandal
we're going to talk a bit about that and
then the fourth story you know i've
wanted to do these throwbacks a little
bit more more often we've done some
things from thomas soul and ronald
reagan and a bunch of others there was a
really great uh video that we found it's
from 60 minutes about 20 years ago
morgan freeman the actor morgan freeman
uh talking to mike wallace about racism
and black history month and how we can
actually move past racism so we thought
in light of everything going on right
now why don't we throw you that one okay
first up though is what's going up uh
what's going on in the great white north
right above us
uh the freedom convoy these truckers who
are protesting mandates and lockdowns
and garnering support all over canada
obviously millions of people but really
millions and millions of people all over
the world they're being called racists
and bigots and transphobes and
islamophobes and anti-semites
by their own prime minister
well they're really just good decent
people i think we've got some video of
these people singing
in ottawa they're singing we are the
world in ottawa there they are waving
canadian flags and there's children and
bright colors and it's very cold out
there so you wouldn't want to be out
there unless you had a real reason to
you can see that woman smiling right
there another woman smiling with the
baby there's a man who appears to be a
government worker and he's with them and
you can see they're pretty decent people
they don't seem to be out there in the
name of transphobia or in the name of
islamaphobia it's all so stupid it's so
stupid when you see the actual videos
and you don't just listen to and
regurgitate what mainstream media is
showing you we've got more uh they
appear
to be dirty hippies
look at this look at this that's a
little bob marley in the background
they're they're dancing and they're
bopping we love truckers truck off
that's a good one
and they're out there and they're
dancing they're not burning effigies of
anyone they're not threatening to kill
or harm anyone
this is all again in the name
of living their lives freely so now
what's interesting about this is this
has obviously been going on for about a
week and you know there were talks was
the canadian government going to bring
in the police or the military to stop
them from protesting freely in a western
society which is pretty much the basis
of western societies
but what's happening now is because they
have not given up they have said we are
here we want to be heard we have some
demands
this is this is what we're doing it and
we're doing it peacefully and the way
it's supposed to be done right they're
not rampaging through ottawa destroying
stores we showed you videos yesterday
they're actually cleaning up after
themselves they're shoveling streets etc
etc well now it's starting to work so
the premiere of alberta which is one of
the western provinces in canada jason
kenny he had this to say yesterday we've
had a lot of protests and a lot of
different people and i think the vast
majority of them
are well-intentioned law-abiding
canadians who are sick and tired
of
how covet has turned their lives upside
down
uh they're frustrated with all kinds of
public health measures
and in many are frustrated in particular
with the quarantine requirement for
cross-border truckers
so to those folks who've been out there
trying to make that point peacefully and
and respectfully uh thank you thank you
for
um using your democratic rights
to do that thank you for
sharing your your passion and your
frustration um and i certainly hear you
by god i share the frustration
please understand that
we
have
tried to
take a minimal approach to restrictions
but a necessary one
to avoid even more damaging
cancellations of surgeries
uh and uh
and and
loss of life
please express that in a way
that
is lawful and peaceful
uh and uh and please
you know don't make a bad situation
worse i'm out there trying to campaign
to end the
quarantine requirement for unvaccinated
cross-border truckers i went down to
washington
in large part to make that case i've
made it to the prime minister i will
continue to
so for those who feel that way i'm on
your side
all right so i don't know much about
jason kenny he seems a little conflicted
like now he's kind of for it but then
he's also you know we've got to be safe
but the broad point here is that this is
because of public pressure do you think
he would be giving this speech where he
clearly you can see he's nervous he's
like oh man am i losing control of my
people and guess what it's the people
who make a government it's not the
government who make a people this is
awesome what is happening here he's
going oh man the truckers and all of
their supporters are demanding freedom
and it's getting to critical mass so i
best get rid of some of these bad
policies now you could sense like he's a
little dishonest in that he's wanted to
get rid of them for a while it seems
okay i guess you probably could have
done it if that's really what you wanted
or you would have been i don't know at
parliament every day fighting with
justin trudeau and the liberals and
everything else
but this is what it's all about there's
a moment with this guys like carpe diem
seize the day man that's what uh that's
what jordan peterson tweeted out to all
of these canadian politicians it's like
you guys have a chance let's say
you were just misled for two years you
made mistakes for two years you were
freaking out for two years
the scientists were were not giving you
clear information you were
overprotective whatever it is it's like
you got a moment right now to stand on
the right side and go alright enough's
enough we're going to let you live and
we're going to see what happens
wouldn't that be good
seize the day jason kenny seize the day
justin trudeau you know i saw one of
those great videos you know they do
those
those hitler videos i haven't done a
show without talking about hitler in a
day or two uh less than that actually um
but you know they do that great hitler
compilation video where they dub in the
the words of somebody else and they did
one with the hitler as justin trudeau i
just thought it was really fantastic
anywho let's move on i want to talk to
you a bit about how awful things are in
california versus how great they are
in florida and that being said as i said
at the top of the show i will be putting
in ten dollars to my escape california
fund which we will be giving all of the
cash at the end of the year depending on
how many times i say california to just
someone we'll figure out who's going to
do it it's probably going to be a local
community member at
rubinreport.locals.com
if you want to relocate from california
to florida i'm just going to give you a
whole bunch of cash i assume it'll be
several thousand dollars at that point
maybe i'll double it or something when
we get to the end of the year we'll see
anyway here's just the stupidity that is
going on in california we showed you
this on monday that on sunday at the big
football game governor gavin newsom and
mayor eric garcetti and san francisco
mayor london breed and magic johnson
they were all at the big football game
and they were maskless they were
maskless now i want you to particularly
look at eric garcetti who's standing
next to magic there
because i'm going to get to some video
of him in just a second
and i usually talk about gavin newsom
gavin newsom's just evil he's is what he
is
magic i think if i'm not mistaken magic
because he's hiv positive is a is in
like a higher risk group so is he
supposed to take the mask off or not
it's his own personal choice so i'm okay
with magic doing whatever you want magic
is also not a politician locking people
down so magic it's good to see your
smile and uh you know i watch old 80s
lakers vs celtics games and i'm doing
cardio so i've got no problem with magic
johnson but eric garcetti over there the
mayor of los angeles one of the most
locked down
destroyed cities
in all of these united states the city
that i just fled well when he got called
out on smiling with magic johnson here
is the load of bs that he tossed at you
you're correct i was very judicious
yesterday
very judicious and you'll see the photo
that i did take
where
magic was kind enough generous enough to
ask me for a photograph and in my left
hand's the mask and i took a photo uh
the rest of the time i wore it
as we all should
not when i had a glass of water or
anything and i encourage everybody else
to do so and uh that's it
all right obviously that was gavin
newsom right there we got the clips
upside down uh but gavin i mean it's
just all you know he takes it over for
the glassware i mean there's so many
videos and pictures of him just sitting
there at the chairs just you know oh
look at me i'm scratching my head i'm
smiling where's your cup of water dude
where's the water are you just a
relentless shameless liar i think we
know the answer dick here's eric
garcetti i wore my mask the entire game
and when people ask for a photograph i
hold my breath and i put it here and
people could see that there's a zero
percent chance of infection from that
i mean think how insane we let them get
away with this stuff right
he holds his breath so that means
someone comes up to him someone comes up
to him and says hey uh mr mayor can i
take a picture with you and they're
already in his face at that point right
so then he takes a breath
you've inhaled all of the stuff at that
point you're holding the stuff in you
in your lungs
you liar we let that he takes it off for
the water he holds his breath these
people are clowns ridiculous but foods
and i wish you luck if you live in
california if you live in los angeles if
you have anything to do that's the
beautiful thing for me i got to tell you
when i lived in california and i would
talk about these people there was there
was an anger in me about it right and an
indignation about it and uh almost like
a complete like how how is this even
possible now it's actually hilarious
there is nothing funnier than that sort
of nonsense to me and now i want to
compare that to what's going on here in
florida because in florida we have a guy
by the name of ron desantis and ron
desantis decided to keep this state open
and this state has incredible
has an incredible economy right now the
amount of tourism is exploding there is
construction everywhere house prices are
high because people are moving here
there is it's just good it's just good
and happy and you see people smile and
you see their teeth and it's awesome
here's ron desantis talking about how
he's going to keep our schools good so
that some of these bad ideas that have
infected everything in these blue states
won't infect the free state of florida
so what we're trying to do with the
legislature is give parents the ability
to inspect the curriculum so they know
what's going on in their schools i think
a lot of parents you know have uh very
strong beliefs about you know how what
is appropriate for for school system to
be discussing and certainly in terms of
like trying to affirmatively push kids
in one direction or another in some of
these areas you know becomes very
problematic and i know parents just they
want to have a basic education so what
we want is you know have curriculum
transparency make sure that the parents
are part of this there are people in our
country and in our state who take the
position that that parents really have
no role in this and that they just need
to be kind of in the dark about what's
going on you know we believe sunlight is
the best uh the best disinfectant and i
think that whether it's things like crt
whether it's other things involving
curriculum having that transparency is
something that's very significant
that's my governor that's right that's
right that is a good man right there and
in essence what he is saying is that
your children
are not the property of the state he's
saying yes we should have public
education we we have tax dollars so that
we can have public schools it's a part
of the exchange that we do here in
america and in most societies you pay
some money in so that you hope you can
send your child to a school to get what
he calls quote a basic education and we
did that pretty decently in america for
about a hundred years pretty decently i
would say
i remember going to public school
elementary junior high high school i
went to a public college as well state
university of new york at binghamton i
got a full public education now i'm not
saying i learned everything absolutely
perfectly and i did come out sort of as
a lefty politically so is what it is but
i remember going to school going to
elementary school learning about slavery
learning about racism learning about
civil rights learning about the
holocaust learning about history and you
got a basic education that was honest
that was decent you said the pledge of
allegiance at the beginning america was
good and these were the ideas that we
were talking about it wasn't to it
wasn't to whitewash any of the bad
things that have happened uh but it was
to give young people a sense of what you
need to know you learn some basic math
where two plus two equals four not two
plus two equals five which is what we're
doing now with this common core nonsense
so he's telling you hey we're going to
get back to the basic stuff and as he
says some parents would like to know
what their kids are learning not because
they're trying to stop their kids from
learning an honest assessment of the
truth but they don't want them to be
brainwashed into all of this gender
stuff in third grade to be taught all of
this crazy gender identity stuff they
don't want to be brainwashed into this
neo-racism that is critical race theory
they want to have a say which by the way
is why all over the country parents are
finally
showing up to school board meetings and
they're fighting back and then of course
the biden administration started calling
them terrorists for doing so um you know
all about that so it's like this is good
and i just got to say one more time i am
very happy to live in a place
where we are governed by someone who
doesn't want to rule over us but someone
who wants us to rule over ourselves and
create room to do just that by creating
places of decent education as opposed to
indoctrination and that's all i got to
say about that let's move over to the
big story yesterday which was cnn
president jeff zucker who has almost
single-handedly destroyed cnn people
think oh it's jeffrey toobin
masturbating that's destroying cnn it's
chris cuomo and his brother with the big
q-tip destroying cnn it's don lemon
pretending to be a journalist destroying
cnn well somebody's in charge of all of
these people and that's the guy by the
name of jeff zucker who's been a tv
executive for decades already he was
pretty well respected in the industry
but he has single-handedly just
demolished cnn the ratings were
absolutely terrible everything else well
yesterday out of nowhere while we were
live on air right here uh he stepped
down we've got some info from the
associated press cnn president jeff
zucker abruptly resigned wednesday after
acknowledging a consensual relationship
with another network executive an
entanglement that came to light during
an investigation of now fired anchor
chris cuomo i acknowledge the
relationship had evolved in recent years
zucker wrote in a memo announcing the
end of his nine year tenure i was
required to disclose it when it began
but i didn't i was wrong in a statement
zucker said he wished that his tenure at
cnn had ended differently but it was an
amazing run and i loved every minute so
let's just do the last part first i mean
by amazing run i mean he he destroyed
cnn cnn is a punchline it's a joke the
reason that mainstream media goes after
joe rogan every day is because joe rogan
is bigger than cnn no matter how big
brian stelter's head is or how big he
says their newsroom is as we covered
yesterday he he destroyed the place now
i actually don't want to spend too much
time on the specifics of his
relationship it sounds like he had a
consensual relationship with another
executive which okay that's just fine so
this isn't a case of sexual harassment
as far as we know
at the moment if he's an adult she's an
adult and they got into a relationship
so be it the company policy from what i
understand and from what he said there
is that if you're going to engage in a
relationship like this then you have to
disclose it to hr they just need to know
about it now that if that's a hr policy
if that's what cnn says this is the way
we do business then i guess he's got to
go um so you know i saw a whole bunch of
people really uh very excited about jeff
zucker stepping down but i don't know
that there was anyone more excited than
orange man yes former president donald
trump he released this statement
jeff zucker a world-class sleazebag who
has headed ratings and real news
challenged cnn for far too long news
challenge cnn for far too long has been
terminated for numerous reasons but
predominantly because cnn has lost its
way with viewers and everybody else
trump said now is a chance to put fake
news in the back seat because there may
not be anything more important than
straightening out the horrendous lame
stream media in our country
and the case of cnn and in the case of
cnn throughout the world jeff zucker is
gone
congratulations to all i thought the end
of that was sort of perfect
congratulations to all like this is like
the end of star wars palpatine got
thrown over the thing in the death star
we're gonna celebrate on all the
different planets congratulations
everybody it's really really great um
look again i don't care about the
specifics of of what he did and if he's
in love with this woman like she loves
him it's like good for you guys like
that's just fine uh if it's a company
policy he broke so be it the bigger
issue here is that as we talk about on
this show every day the the mainstream
ability the corporate press ability to
keep any of us feeling like they're
telling us the truth has been completely
destroyed by people like jeff zucker i
mean his tenure at cnn was a disaster
so
even though it's kind of good let's say
for a guy like me right like i just tell
you what i think you can agree or not
agree you can watch or not watch you can
share a video or not watch but because
they're so bad it does drive people to
us right so on one hand it's like all
right let them keep crumbling but i
truly mean this it would be much better
for the country as a whole uh and i
don't believe i'm not like one of these
polyanisha people that believes that you
can just magically make everybody come
together and have these kumbaya moments
especially anymore maybe there were ways
to do it before the internet or maybe 10
or 15 years ago something like that i
don't think you can do it anymore but
would it be better
if when people turned on what was the
most trusted name in news that it was
trusted would it be better when people
opened up the new york times that was
once all the news that's fit to print
was actually all the news that's fit to
print and not all the news that's fit to
make up or you know turn into propaganda
or whatever it might be or leak stories
from the democratic administration and
leak stories about a republican
administration you guys get all that
like of course that would be better so
if you're somebody that's gonna maybe
take the interim job at cnn i wish you
luck i really do i really really do and
i hope you put on a freaking kick-ass
show at 11 a.m eastern right up against
the ruin report that is so good that
people stop watching this show
but i don't think it's gonna happen uh
and to all of that point uh there's
something else interesting going on in
the cable news situation related to
tucker carlson and i thought this was
really really maybe indicative of what
what is bigger
than just jeff zucker stepping down
because of the because of this
relationship this might really be the
reason he's stepping down we've got some
info from the rap in october tucker
carlson's 9 p.m eastern program was the
top cable news show among democrats in
the advertiser coveted age range of 25
to 54. fox news also commanded the
largest number of independents in the
key news demo during prime time and
total day hours 55 of those 25 to 54
watch the network in prime time compared
to cnn's 23
and msnbc's 22
during total day hours 58 of
independents in the demo watch fox news
18 chose msnbc and 25 selected cnn more
surprising are the stats about carlson
and fox news's poll with self-proclaimed
democrats of those demo-aged viewers
surveyed who identified as democrats 39
chose fox news 31 chose msnbc and 30
chose cnn for programming from 8 to 11
pm eastern in total day viewership fox
news grabbed 42 percent of democrats
aged 25 to 54 cnn nab 33 and msnbc got
25. so look the key part here without
getting lost
in ratings or how actually legit they
are or how many people are walking by
things at bars or at you know uh
airports wherever it might be the key
thing here is that
tucker
is crushing it with relatively young
democrats
do you see the shift that is taking
place
do you guys see it like there is
something massive taking place and when
you add all of these stories up
the the people that lie losing audience
the people that are telling the truth or
selling telling something approximate to
the truth or talking about what peop
real people care about that their
numbers are blowing up whether it's
tucker or rogan or whatever it might be
it's like there's a move happening you
throw in the trucker thing and you see
people standing up something good is
happening
or i'm just drinking a lot of coffee i'm
not sure but i think it's probably both
actually to be quite frank all right we
got one more for you i wanted to do a
little throwback clip because uh
february is black history month as they
say
that's what i'm told in my google
calendar and we found this video of
morgan freeman on 60 minutes this is
about 20 years ago
talking to mike wallace
about uh the importance or perhaps the
insignificance of black history month
black history month you find
ridiculous why
you're going to relegate my history to a
month
oh come on what do you do with yours
what which month is white history month
come on tell me well
i'm jewish
okay which month is jewish history month
now there isn't one oh
oh
why not yeah do you want one no no no
i don't either
i don't want a black history month
black history is american history
how are we going to get rid of racism
talking about it
i'm going to stop calling you a white
man
yeah i'm going to ask you to stop
calling me
a black
man i know you as mike wallace you know
me as morgan freeman you want to say
what
i know this white guy named mike wallace
you know what i'm saying
pretty good huh
remember the old days when you could
turn on network television and hear
something that actually made sense um
look we've got a month for everything
there's gay pride month there's black
history month we got months for all of
these things it's all of this sort of
symbolic silliness but the real moment
in that the kernel in that little video
there
is when
morgan freeman looks directly at mike
wallace after he says he's jewish and he
goes do you want one meaning do you want
a month a jewish history month maybe
there is one i actually don't even know
they probably added one since
do you want one and mike wallace is
right no
why would i want one of those man i
don't want that
that tells you all you need to know
these things have nothing to do with
solving the problems we did such a
freaking good job in america of solving
these problems think about where we were
at ten years ago before we let wokeness
and blm and this modern pernicious
racism of the left into the system
when we voted in that two-time black
president
barack obama with hope and change
whether you liked obama or not i mean
america did vote in a black president
how many european countries have black
prime ministers right like we did
something so well
that we are watching a race right now
and morgan's free morgan freeman's broad
point there
is stop talking about it meaning the
more you obsess over it the more you
make it feel real and the more that it
feels real the more people will act on
that fake realism and we'll all walk
around thinking that everything is
racist so that's a great point morgan
freeman doesn't sit down in that
interview and go who am i talking to
today oh it's it's
it's white anchor mike wallace and i
hope that mike wallace didn't sit down
that day and go who am i talking to it's
black actor morgan freeman no one cares
about this stuff anymore except the
wolksters yes is are there 50 neo-nazis
somewhere
yeah there are
there are a couple do they have any
institutional power does anyone give
them the time of day
no should they be allowed to be outside
holding a flag yeah free speech okay
but
we have to get to the point and we were
so close i mean that's really the point
we were so close to getting to the point
where we were post-race and just as we
were there they pulled the rug out and
now made everything about race and we
cannot let that if america is going to
continue
we can't let it win
so that's what our work is and uh i like
doing work uh on locals we got a bunch
of comments from reubenport.locals.com
amy said the old i didn't inhale excuse
again can we can we show that garcetti
thing one more time i mean this guy
is just really think about it he has
that's what i'm saying you know when i
said the thing yesterday from from
jordan peterson about justin trudeau
like his complete inability to tell the
truth it's like all of them they have
this inability to say something true
here's the clip i wore my mask the
entire game and when people ask for a
photograph i hold my breath and i put it
here and people could see that there's a
zero percent chance of infection from
that
there's a zero percent chance of
infection when you hold your breath
while taking a picture that is complete
nonsense
these people should be taken away i'm
not for the gulags but like take these
people away not magic
i'd love to play ball of magic leave
magic around but like the other guys
they gotta go and again magic's not a
politician kell says who believes magic
johnson would ask for a picture with
this idiot i'm sure it was the other way
around i honestly don't know i don't
know anything about magic johnson's
politics and that's the way i like it
because the more you find out about you
know your childhood heroes politics or
what they think about this or that the
more you stop liking them the fact that
i don't i know magic only to be an
awesome top 10 basketball player of all
time a guy with like a perpetual smile
who has done so much work i mean
ironically magic he's standing there
with two of these crazy far left
progressives who've done so much damage
to the inner city and so much damage to
the black community magic has put tons
and tons of money by creating businesses
magic johnson movie theaters all sorts
of strip malls in la now maybe he got
some kickbacks maybe there were some
deals that were made with those guys i'm
not saying even illegal like maybe there
was they worked together to make some of
that happen but magic believes in in
capitalism magic believes in the
you creating something good for your own
community which is completely the
reverse of what those two clowns believe
uh roberts says thank you mainstream
media for trying to vilify joe rogan i
found his podcasts this morning and i'm
and i'm enjoying his discussion with
jordan peterson well that's even the
funnier part because the more that they
call us all neo-nazis and racists and
misinformation specialists and
conspiracy theorists and all of these
other scary things then what happens is
people go well they're saying all these
bad things about rogan maybe i'll in the
privacy of my own home maybe i'll listen
to one of these podcasts and then you
listen and you go oh
yeah some interesting questions maybe i
agree with him on some stuff maybe i
don't i mean i can tell you guys this do
i agree with joe rogan on everything no
joe rogan was a bernie supporter joe
rogan the guy who lived in california
was fed up with taxes and moved to texas
while supporting bernie like that
doesn't really make a lot of sense to me
does that make him evil no maybe he's a
little confused about the issues or
maybe he's evolved on that i mean
who the hell knows it doesn't even
matter it doesn't even matter he's
willing to have those conversations so
the more that they do this and by the
way this is what they've done with
everyone the more that you do this even
to someone like alex jones who i've told
you guys before i don't think i've ever
watched five
full minutes
of of alex jones show yeah i've seen the
things of him screaming and frogs are
making people gay and whatever else it
is um but the more you say that this guy
is the most evil thing out there unless
he is
because you got to call evil out when
it's evil right if you had someone out
there in the public sphere in america
right now with real influence who was
really like we have to go back to when
black people were slaves and jews
couldn't go to school and women couldn't
vote and all that stuff and then he
started gaining this huge popular
audience yeah you'd want to call it out
i wouldn't be for silencing his speech
but you'd want to call it out but the
more
they cry wolf with people
and again this isn't about alex jones
specifically this isn't about joe rogan
or anyone else the more they cry wolf
about all of us justin trudeau calling
all of those truckers islamophobes and
transphobes that's why they created the
convoy
because of their irrational fear of
trans people it's like the more they do
that
the more powerful we will become
ladles and jelly spoons my full
interview with glenn beck is up on
reubenreport.locals right now part one
is up on the blaze and oh no part well
the full thing's up on blaze as well but
part one is up on youtube and rumble
today clip 2 will be up a little bit
later today and if you want to play
along during any of these live shows and
maybe have your comment or question read
during the show check out
reubenreport.locals.com
goodbye
you